while a few moments could top the
surprises of the 2023 Oscars Jamie Lee
Curtis's win at the 95th Academy Awards
left a certain Marvel actor in the cold
Angela bassett's extraordinary
performance in Black Panther wakanda
forever just wasn't quite enough to earn
her the best actress in a supporting
role Oscar at the 95th Academy Awards
following her previous Oscar snub for
her performance as Tina Turner she's now
all for two on the big night even
without the golden statue bassett's
riveting portrayal of Queen raimonda
remains a high point in the thespian's
career in her place the award wound up
in the hands of Jamie Lee Curtis for her
performance in everything everywhere all
at once as Ariana Dubose who won the
same award last year shouted out
Curtis's name the camera focused on a
visual graphic of all the nominees and
their responses putting up a stoic
expression Bassett seemed on the verge
of tears from the disappointment she
must have felt in the moment it seems
that bassett's subdued reaction was
fairly palpable as one redditor wrote I
thought Angela was going wins so I was
watching her face as they read the
winner she seemed so disappointed the
reality of the moment may have weighed
heavily on Bassett but she handled the
defeat with Grace many superhero fans
must have been crushed to hear Jaime Lee
Curtis's name announced rather than
bassets and there certainly weren't any
wakanda forever chants in the room that
night and how do you feel about that
bassett's expression wasn't the best of
Poker faces either but to the thespian's
credit she kept her cool and merely
tilted her head to the right with the
slightest of motions meanwhile fellow
nominee Hong Chao who was nominated for
her role in the whale showed what a good
sport she was by smiling and applauding
for Curtis's First Academy Award win
Kerry Condon seemed less enthused but
she still offered a smile however the
best reaction by far went to Curtis's
co-star and fellow nominee Stephanie Shu
while Curtis herself appeared
flabbergasted by the victory Shu
exploded with genuine Delight screaming
at her castmates Victory while bassett's
loss was devastating Curtis's victory
was well deserved the actor had never
been nominated for an Oscar before and
her prolific career dates all the way
back to her portrayal of a teenager
running for Michael Myers in John
Carpenter's Halloween thanks to that
role she's a legendary scream queen and
a two-time recipient of fangoria's
Chainsaw Awards decades later it was
with the momentum she built from that
first performance that she was finally
labeled an oscar-winning performer while
many film fans were delighted to see
Jamie Lee Curtis finally win an Oscar a
large contingent of viewers believe
Angela Bassett was robbed one Twitter
user claimed that her reaction to losing
actually hurt to watch and this view
summed up the feelings of many other
social media users who tuned in to view
the event live elsewhere another user
tweeted that the Black Panther will come
to Forever star really wanted to win the
prize and her visible disappointment can
be chalked up as a natural reaction
writing Angela bassett's reaction to
Jamie Lee Curtis's name being called you
can tell how much that Oscar would have
meant to her she is was and always will
be incredible some viewers also
criticized the Oscars for sliding
another black panther star especially
after Chadwick Boseman missed out on the
best actor prize for a moraines black
bottom in 2021 writing the academy is so
nasty like first y'all robbed Chadwick
Boseman after his death and then you rob
Angela Bassett of her Oscar that she was
nominated for in a movie that honors
Chadwick every member of the academy got
a permanent spot in hell
[Music]